I remember hearing about gray at ABCD
camp you know people were comparing him
to Bill Russell and I mean you don't get
compared to Bill Russell when you're 17
years old standing
we had our schools that we both like
like Michigan State I like North
Carolina our last visit that we took was
together at Ohio State we sat there in
the arena talking to that Mata and it
kind of looked at each other and was
like are we gonna do this
me and Mike decided to come to the Ohio
State University when I go to Ohio State
he's like if it's cool with you you know
that says how you this was the place
that we both feel comfortable being at a
place where we know we can grow as young
men I wanted you know to bring a
national championship here our
expectations going into the tournament
we felt like we were a championship
caliber team
[Applause]
the NCAA tournament Xavier I was sitting
on the bench like I'm about to have a
spring break for the first time in my
life
and then the overtime came in Mike
Conley I think he got seven points to
start the overtime meet him was watching
the film after in the hotel and just
looking at him smile and actually seeing
all that that worked and that emotion he
put out there we're getting kids at the
time just enjoying it and being able to
watch the film it was just like that
really happened man I can't believe that
happened and felt like we couldn't lose
that fit we definitely knew how good
Tennessee was rebound Tennessee I mostly
remember my black shot at the end of the
game
Ron loo like screamed in my face
afterwards and I blocked that shot my
chin had hit the ground and when it had
hit the ground he like cracks oh man my
teeth and it's both so many of my
cavities we won the game but I was like
I was at the dentist for the next five
weeks
[Applause]
his presence offensively defensively he
changes the whole dynamic of a whole
team we're so used to having him there
as an anchor
in Florida for the national championship
that national championship game you know
we're all nervous sitting in the locker
room and we're like let's comes miles
gonna say it again up and then he walks
in he turns off the light and he puts on
this clip from wedding crashers damn you
almost know Chuck do you realize Oh
almost no Chucky that's what we watched
before the national championship game
and then the game started I think our
sense of urgency kind of kicked in a
little bit too late you fool a lot of
bodies out of the strength of our team
was that we just could keep throwing
Biggs at him and good ones too Joakim
Noah out Horford those are the guys that
I had to go up against so yeah I
definitely got tired okay they
definitely wore me out that team was a
great team you know two national
championships that I need to tell the
Florida fans that but doing the Gator
Chomp - eighteen year old kid after he
just lost the national championship is I
almost cried walking off that court
right there you know what I would've I
didn't crying - I'm happy we won though
I loved it here in Columbus Ohio but
when the opportunity comes would be the
number one draft pick I think you got to
take that with the first pick in the
2007 NBA Draft the Portland Trailblazers
select Greg Oden from Ohio State
University
it's gonna give books to pick
[Applause]
those knees
when I was MBA Claire for those six
years I was rarely on the floor just
with all those injuries I've had I
didn't feel like I did enough I
physically could not do it it was like
if I gave one good day of that hard work
the next three days I spent rehab and
just trying to get my knees to feel good
for me to sit down or walk down the
stairs and if so much pain I was going
through just to try to get myself to the
level I wanted to be at I think bus is a
tough term because his was injury driven
not skill driven we all saw what you can
do as athleticism his ability
there's no bust about that people who
call whatever they want to bus in the
context compared to some I can see it
that way too
and then some people get mad at me for
saying that if I don't talk that way
about yourself and I go okay yeah but
you know it's just a word when I was
deciding if I was gonna be done playing
basketball it was definitely a mental
switch I had to make a lot of watching
old YouTube clips and you know crying by
myself I picked up the phone and called
coach Matta it was actually the greatest
thing I did he was just like come be
around the program come be around the
guys stay around basketball stay around
you know just basketball minds you know
keeping that open to give me a reason to
wake up and just go to the gym you know
to see people when big fella told me he
was going back to school to be a coach
get his degree I was happy I was proud
of him so when I graduate I want my spot
to be right here I'm gonna graduate
undergrad in Maine don't second-guess
ain't backing you straight up I want to
go into coaching next I really enjoy
trying to figure out this new game a
basketball he's got so much to teach and
so much to you know give these guys I
hope they enjoy having me here I hope
I'm telling them things that's gonna
impact their lives on and off the court
and I hope they enjoy it as much as I do
what's up you guys it's Taylor Brooks
with bleach to report make sure that you
subscribe for more video content